boa leute ist das spannend kurz vor der
wahl taumelt armin laschet richtungen
wahlniederlage es geht tatsächlich um
viel vielleicht zu kommen alles für die
union manche glauben das rennen ist
schon gelaufen andere sagen pustekuchen
alles drin auf jeden fall steht es spitz
auf knopf ich bin armin laschet
und ich weiß dass wir das können und ich
bin david gebhard und ich weiß das wird
wohl verdammt eng für armin laschet ist
der drops schon gelutscht was spricht
dafür was spricht dagegen
[Applaus]
klar ist die umfragen sind mies für die
cdu aber vor allem für armin laschet
persönlich da liegt er meilenweit hinter
seinem konkurrenten olaf scholz doch
fangen wir mit der haben seite an was
spricht dafür dass armin laschet das
ruder noch rumreißen kann
[Musik]
zunächst einmal bayern münchen klingt
komisch ist aber irgendwie so denn wie
bei laschet und seine union heißt es
beim fc bayern zwar auch manchmal so was
gibt's ja mal ne scheiße läuft am ende
ist dann aber der fc bayern doch fast
immer meister und so ähnlich wie im
fußball ist es auch in der politik
schaut man auf die wahlergebnisse dann
sieht man 16 mal hatte die union die
nase vorn und nur dreimal die spd einmal
2002 sogar nur hauchdünn also die
bundesrepublik deutschland bild
historisch gesehen jedenfalls doch fast
immer schwarz und genau darauf hofften
jetzt eben viele in der cdu mit denen
man spricht dass es am ende wieder so
kommt am ende des tages steht ja kein
kanzler gewählt sondern es wird eine
politische partei gewählt wir stehen auf
dem stimmzettel mit den parteien und
nicht mit dem kanzlerkandidaten
das klingt irgendwie so ein bisschen
verzweifelt wählt uns trotz armin
laschet als cdu aber auch armin laschet
persönliche historie bietet grund zur
hoffnung für die cdu denn er hat schon
so einige dinge zu seinen gunsten noch
gedreht
[Musik]
totgesagte leben länger das trifft
insbesondere auf armin laschet zu das
hat uns sein biograf erzählt armin
laschet leben aber auch vor allem seine
politische karriere haben gezeigt dass
man ihn nie unterschätzen sollte und
dass man ihnen vor allem auch nie
abschreiben sollte das ist schon viel zu
oft geschehen geschehen zb 2017 in
nordrhein westfalen die amtsinhaberin
hannelore kraft lag damals fast
uneinholbar vorn in den umfragen 11 12
und armin laschet lag abgeschlagen
dahinter keiner dachte eigentlich so
richtig daran dass laschet das noch
drehen kann und auf den letzten metern
zucker in ihr vorbei und wurde
ministerpräsident in nordrhein westfalen
und das erzählen haben jetzt immer
wieder in hintergrundgesprächen unions
politiker die sagen da hat das doch
schon mal geschafft brauchen besonders
diesmal nicht wieder schaffen oder auch
innerparteilich da hatten doch viele auf
friedrich merz als parteivorsitzenden
getippt und laschet hat am ende auf dem
parteitag das ding für sich gedreht vor
allem mit einer für seine verhältnisse
ziemlich guten rede und auch markus
söder beim showdown um die
kanzlerkandidatur hatte gegen armin
laschet das nachsehen was bis heute an
ihm nagt jedenfalls hat armin laschet
mit zähigkeit auch den bayerischen löwen
aus dem rennen gekickt mit ordentlich
hilfestellungen von wolfgang schäuble
allerdings aber sei es drum am ende
blieb immer armin laschet übrig
irgendwie unkaputtbar und das führen
jetzt gerade die für ihn ins feld die
eigentlich immer gegen ihn waren die
jungen nun hat sich auch schon mal für
markus söder und auch friedrich merz ein
gesetz am ende hat sich das stellt immer
durchgesetzt deswegen bin ich mir sicher
er wird sich am ende bei dieser
bundestagswahl durchsetzen das problem
daran ist dass da irgendwie immer
mitschwingt eigentlich war für uns nur
dritte wahl aber gut armin laschet hat
bewiesen dass er zähigkeit hat und
stehvermögen und das könnte ihm so sehr
wie er gerade unter druck ist auf den
letzten metern helfen
[Musik]
selbst wenn armin laschet am ende hinter
scholz und der spd liegt hofft er auf
ihn schon dass christian lindner der fdp
chef am ende zum urlaub sagt es ist
besser nicht zu regieren als falsch zu
regieren dann nämlich wenn eine
rechnerisch mögliche rot grün rote
koalition meine kollegin andrea maurer
dazu eine ziemlich coole folge gemacht
hier könnt ihr auch noch anschauen wenn
die nicht zustande kommt dann hat
christian lindner sozusagen das heft in
der hand dass christian lindner machen
könnte wäre olaf scholz dann nämlich zu
sagen wir haben keine gemeinsamkeiten
für eine koalition mit grünen und der
spd
also zum beispiel bei der steuerpolitik
passt das nicht zusammen und dann zu
sagen jamaika das ist das einzige wo die
fdp sich für hergeben würde dann könnte
armin laschet quasi als wahlverlierer
der hinter der spd liegt doch nach
kanzler werden sozusagen wenn sich
lindner an den ketten und dem olaf
scholz das hat er jetzt schon mal im
bundestag gemacht droht
1976 hat helmut kohl sogar die erfahrung
machen müssen dass man wahlen gewinnen
kann und danach trotzdem keine koalition
hat lindner treibt so natürlich den
preis in die höhe für sich und seine fdp
aber die grünen könnten ihnen natürlich
auch noch in die suppe spucken denn ob
die wirklich jamaika machen wollen wenn
die spd vor der union legt die basis da
wirklich mitspielen würde das ist eher
unwahrscheinlich wir werden sehen
jedenfalls ist es ein strohhalm vor
armin laschet und sein team und seine
strategen und in diverse auch ein
typischer laschet am ende als quasi
wahlverlierer vielleicht doch noch
kanzler zu werden aber eigentliches
platz 1 ein muss für eine union mit
ihrem selbstverständnis als nummer eins
in deutschland jedenfalls hoffen jetzt
ganz viele mit denen man spricht auf den
merkel effekt dass angela merkel mit
ihrer popularität armin laschet quasi
noch an der hand über die ziellinie
zieht ins kanzleramt lange hatte sie
sich aber demonstrativ rausgeholt und
viele riefen immer wieder nach merkel
aber sie blieb irgendwie seltsam
abwesend jetzt hat sie sich doch
eingemischt eigentlich seit der
spd-kanzlerkandidat sich symbolisch in
ihre nachfolge gestellt hat und jetzt
hält die bundeskanzlerin da geht
unser land ist eine cdu csu geführte
bundesregierung mit armin laschet als
bundeskanzler das ist natürlich jetzt
nicht so überraschend dass eine cdu
kanzlerin den aktuellen cdu kanzler
kandidaten unterstützt muss sie
natürlich in ihrer eigenen emotionalen
art das bisschen das was ich ihnen schon
sagen kann dann mit dem herzen bin ich
natürlich sehr dabei natürlich sehr
dabei es wird aber auch zeit bei diesem
wahlkampf
[Musik]
im netz kursieren jedenfalls schon alle
möglichen sportbäder über armin laschet
zum beispiel als riese mit blauen haaren
der die cdu selbst zerstört wie konnte
es so weit kommen und was macht das mit
laschet wir haben armin laschet mal in
seinem wahlkampf beobachtet und gemerkt
dass ihn seine fehler auch immer wieder
einholen wie in dieser szene zum
beispiel warum haben sie gelacht hat sie
gefragt habe sag das mal nämlich das war
ein fehler aber ich sage ihnen ich
ärgere mich darüber leisten die frau
meint diese situation her armin laschet
und der bundespräsident im hochwasser
der bundespräsident redet über die opfer
der flugkatastrophe und armin laschet im
hintergrund gut zu erkennen feixt lacht
und es irgendwie mit seinen gedanken
ganz woanders das fanden viele ich
übrigens auch ziemlich daneben und das
hat ihm auch sehr geschadet
[Musik]
laschet und sein team wirken oft
getrieben und unorganisiert in diesem
wahlkampf kürzlich zum beispiel stellte
er seinen zukunftsteam vor mit acht
experten für acht system und wer war zum
beispiel nicht dabei der außenpolitische
experte nummer eins in der union
herrsche norbert röttgen teer fehlte
irgendwie auch jens spahn für gesundheit
war nicht dabei sondern eher no names
und quereinsteiger außer friedrich merz
natürlich aber der war schon in den
letzten wochen so was wie der running
mate von armin laschet gewesen und
deswegen auch nicht wirklich neu und
überraschend und dann diese begebenheit
armin laschet geht hart ins gericht mit
der bilanz der eigenen unionsgeführten
bundesregierung wir sind digital nicht
so aufgestellt wie wir es sein müssten
und wie auch unser anspruch ist da
präsentiert er ausgerechnet die
staatsministerin für digitalisierung im
kanzleramt csu frau b und die war
eigentlich in den letzten vier jahren ja
schon das gesicht für den zustand den
armin laschet kurz zuvor als ziemlich
desolat beschrieben hat nicht besonders
glaubwürdig und dann die sache mit dem
klima team kennt ihr die namen bisher
jedenfalls scheinen alle teams von
laschet nicht wirklich zu ziehen und am
ende kommt es dann doch vor allem auf
den an der vorne steht und der der vorne
steht durchläuft gerade eine wundersame
wandlung
[Musik]
es geht auch nicht dass olaf scholz olaf
scholz verweigert und ich fordere olaf
scholz aus haben wir in armin schulz
den humor scheint armin laschet immerhin
noch nicht verloren zu haben aber er
macht seinen konkurrenten olaf scholz
natürlich umso größer umso öfter er auch
seinen namen selber in den mund wir
erinnern uns an angela merkel die hat es
ja geschafft ganze wahlkämpfe lang den
namen ihres herausforderers nicht einmal
in den mund zu nehmen manche unten ghasi
habe sie gar nicht gekappt armin laschet
gibt sich jedenfalls jetzt auffallend
aggressiv attacke aber irgendwie passt
es halt einfach nicht zu dem image das
er sich zuvor immer wieder gerne selbst
gegeben hat armin laschet ist ein
vermittler ein moderator maß und mitte
lautet sein regierungs motto in
nordrhein westfalen und ist er ist
jemand aber auch stolz darauf der
zusammenführt jovial locker rheinische
frohnatur einer der zusammenführt aber
das alles sind natürlich attribute die
jetzt im wahlkampf wo der attackierende
gefordert ist teilweise kämpferisch
mitunter vielleicht auch schmutzig
überhaupt nicht gefragt und diese beiden
bilder nebeneinander gelegt die passen
einfach nicht passen tut armin laschet
auch vielen in der eigenen partei nicht
zumindest als der kanzlerkandidat der
vorne steht
[Musik]
die beleidigte schwester cs die macht
armin laschet das leben schon seit
monaten schwer denn die hätten
eigentlich einen ganz anderen gewalt
markus söder war erkennbar der kandidat
der herzen so und jetzt ist die csu eben
nicht wirklich mit dem herzen dabei
armin laschet zu unterstützen zum
beispiel markus söder der nämlich kann
immer wieder das eine sagen und das
andere ausstrahlen der nächste
bundeskanzler heißt
unterstützung aller markus zuerst man
hat den eindruck in der staatskanzlei in
münchen steht eine ganze nähmaschine die
tag und nacht sticheleien versetzt
ratter ratter ratter ein albtraum von
landsleute immer wieder die süder so
tropft es wirklich aus den knopflöchern
und aus allen interviews er will zeigen
dass er eigentlich der bessere gewesen
wäre und so führt man keinen wahlkampf
in der cdu jedenfalls sind einige
komplett genervt persönlich ist ein
guter wahlkämpfer
aber wir brauchen an der spitze keine
solisten sondern wir brauchen einen
teamplayer doch an teamplay fehlt es
eben gerade die einen sind von söder
genervt die anderen von laschet und der
wird dann auch von einigen im wahlkampf
komplett versteckt ich war kürzlich im
cdu straßenwahlkampf unterwegs man
riecht man von ferne eine rostbratwurst
sieht große plakate und aufsteller von
direktkandidaten über verschiedene
themen aber kein armin laschet dabei ist
er doch der kanzlerkandidat also man hat
das gefühl zum teil wird er richtig
versteckt wir haben selbst
wahrscheinlich das werbematerial des
bundesverbandes auch dabei
und das machen wir sozusagen natürlich
auch auf dann unter der theke ein ja
also wir machen wahlkampf für armin
laschet weil wir als team auch antreten
ich glaube dass manchmal ein bisschen
frustration mit dabei und auch
unsicherheit was kommt jetzt und was
haben wir von laschet zu erwarten wir
geben ja trotzdem folgart trotzdem die
stimmung ist so lala auch bei den
kollegen in brandenburg bringen der
straßenwahlkampf ist nicht schön im
moment man spürt eine gewisse
frustration aus unterschiedlichsten
gründen wir versuchen das mit unserer
persönlichkeit mit unserer hacke vor ort
abzufedern laschet effekt abfedern und
wenn man mit den cdu wahlkämpfer mal
vertraulich spricht also im reichstags
flur in der pause dann erzählen wir eine
noch ganz andere sachen so was wie ich
habe ja laschet flyer im auto aber die
lasse ich lieber im kofferraum weil das
sind eher ladenhüter und einer sprach
sogar von abschreckungs material laschet
hat natürlich weiterhin auch fans in der
cdu aber es sind auch keine
einzelstimmen und die stimmung ist kurz
vor der wahl unter den wahlkämpfern
wirklich nicht gut
[Musik]
also zeit für ein fazit armin laschet
kann natürlich die wahl noch gewinnen
hat er schließlich gegen hannelore kraft
friedrich merz und markus söder
irgendwie auch geschafft aber armin
laschet kann natürlich die wahl auch
verlieren die stimmung hinter den
kulissen in der union ist total mies und
die lage super ernst für ein wie cdu
grande wolfgang schäuble sagen würde ich
aber ist es definitiv zu früh auch wenn
es abgenudelt klingt umfragen sind
einfach keine wahlergebnisse und im am
abgrund tänzelnd ist armin laschet
tatsächlich schon irgendwie sowas wie
der meister was glaubt ihr stürzt armin
laschet ab oder handelte sich doch noch
irgendwie wieder zurück nach umschreibt
es in die kommentare und abonniert
unseren kanal zdf heute wenn ihr kein
video mehr verpassen wollt schaut in
unserer playlist vorbei inside politics
denn inside politics ist das format der
herzen